une légende tibétaine raconte qu'un
jour dieu vishva karma est descendu du ciel
et placé le plus ancien sur la montagne ghe pel
représentation d'une divinité est la
statue d'un géant dont le sourire
hermétique contient l'expression de tous
les idoles du monde
[Musique]
ces géants sont les anciens
astronautes mentionnés dans les mythologies de
monde entier de rangs différents ces
les géants sont appelés anunnaki dai
Elohim sumérien des Hébreux l'osse dai
grecs d'eva par des indiens et avec d'autres
noms selon les lieux avec un
technologie très avancée
ces géants sont 600 mâles et femelles
leur durée de vie est millénaire
et utilisent généralement le
modification génétique et clonage
arrivé sur terre et dans le besoin
de main-d'œuvre pour leurs avant-postes i
les géants produisent des créatures étranges
dans les sous-produits génétiques généraux qui
finir par éliminer quand
ils font leur meilleur produit
homme terrestre
[Musique]
pas plus que des milliers ne s'effondrent et ne produisent
enfin la femme pour que ces nouveaux
les créatures se multiplient d'elles-mêmes
ayant maintenant un peuple de
ouvriers les géants se partagent
monde, chacun formant une nation mais
car leur caractère est guerrier
ils font la guerre pour des raisons de
territoire
de leur côté les premiers humains vénèrent
ces géants qui les ont créés et là
ils prennent pour des dieux mais la relation
n'est pas amical
ces dieux fournissent la nourriture comme
ils font les éleveurs mais ils traitent les
humains comme s'ils étaient du bétail e
ils punissent les désobéissants et les célèbres
jugement
dans cette équipe d'astronautes
explorateurs chaque géant un technicien
spécialisé dans une discipline
spécifique il y a le dieu du volcan de feu
qui forge les éclairs de Zeus le dieu de
vent euro
Moi de l'eau neptune le dieu de
asclépios médecine le dieu de la guerre
Mars et les autres
loin de leur planète
ces dieux aiment se saouler à la bière
bière d'orge inventée en egypte par
d'Osiris qui le construit dans un temple
caché dans l'embouchure du nil pour
garder le secret la bière arrive
sur mer où la déesse en anna lui offre je
ses prêtres dans le temple d'uruk
[Musique]
en sicile la déesse déméter la cultive
l'hébergement lui-même et produit l'action du visage
et la bière, vénérée par les romains, la bière
a été déclaré monopole d'État depuis
pharaon sety son fils ramses ii parle
prescrit un tribut de mille amphores
l'année pour la demeure du temple de dendera
de la déesse mère de la tour à babylone la
code d'hammurabi conçoit pour le
bière la première plateforme tarifaire
de l'histoire
en plus d'avoir ces dieux qu'ils aiment inhaler
la fumée émise par la graisse brûlée pour
entrer en contact avec eux
il suffit d'allumer un feu et
sacrifier un animal attiré par nous
sentir l'idée et ils arrivent
invariablement et récompenser
écraser jusqu'à ce que les leurs soient éliminés
adversaires parmi les géants du sexe
femmes toutes de haut rang
les plus célèbres sont l'étoile de assumerai
les idées égyptiennes dans la tour isis la déesse
Athéna grecque et bien d'autres
ces idées règnent sur leurs territoires
établir le matriarcat l'année dure
364 jours et est divisé en 13 mois lunaires
de 28 jours comme le cycle menstruel
la succession au trône se fait par la voie
féminin et à partir du treizième mois la
Regina sacrifie un roi dont le
superstition du nombre 13 dans
matriarcat les femmes sont protégées par un
concept fort de chasteté établissant
cultes dédiés aux idées vierges
jusqu'à la Madone actuelle
[Musique]
parmi les idées la déesse mère est la plus
son image est vénérée la trinité
lunaire ou croissant de lune de la déesse
vierge athéna la pleine lune de la déesse
aphrodite et la lune décroissante de la déesse était
[Musique]
cette trinité est symbolisée par le
masque de la méduse une femme avec des dieux
serpents au lieu de cheveux qui
terrifie ceux qui regardent ça
l'intention d'effrayer survient lorsque le
vierge athéna subit un accident
ne portant qu'un bouclier sur elle
qui est représenté la méduse athéna a
besoin d'une armure et passe donc de
dieu du volcan dans sa fonderie de l'etna
pour qu'un volcan soit fait
depuis quelque temps il regardait avec des yeux avides
la jeune vierge profite
de l'occasion et saute sur elle prêt
la violer
mais Athéna se protège avec le bouclier et le
les méduses effraient tellement le volcan que le
la jeune fille réussit à s'enfuir
[Musique]
depuis les filles méditerranéennes
ils portent une robe de chasteté
pour lequel la méduse est représentée
terroriser les hommes qui attaquent
à leur virginité
en europe le matriarcat décline quand
un peuple hyperboréen quitte l'actuel
Lettonie et arrive en Méditerranée
envahir les îles des mers égéennes ioniennes
ce peuple sont les anciens grecs
Homère raconte les exploits de leurs dieux
test mais les événements qu'il mentionne ont eu
endroit dans la baltique et non en grèce où
il n'y a pas de soleil de minuit dans
la glace
cette invasion apporte le culte solaire
le mâle reprend les pleins pouvoirs e
il transmet l'héritage à ses fils
quand le roi meurt une cérémonie est renouvelée
sa vie pendant toute une journée
le remplaçant règne à sa place mais le soir
après avoir mangé son dernier souper
cet homme est sacrifié
[Musique]
les viandes du substitut et du roi sont
alors mangez et leur sang est
répandre sur les champs pour le fertiliser
[Musique]
en Inde lors de la fête liturgique de
chakra puglia 12 participants sous le
guide d'un maître boit le sang
de la déesse shakti et manger les viandes des
dieu shiva dans la même cérémonie
Eucharistique de la Dernière Cène de Jésus a
cette ancienne tradition s'inspire
sacrifice de la Pâque chrétienne pour le
besoin d'un mort pour la vie
être renouvelé parmi les dieux qui meurent
s'offrant en sacrifice pour ressusciter
dans une nouvelle vie il y a le dieu
égyptien osiris l'enfant dieu réinitialiser un
monza le dieu aztèque quetzalcóatl et beaucoup
les autres jusqu'au Christ le dieu rédempteur
des chrétiens
la performance de ces géants qui
ils ne meurent jamais en allant et venant
ciel à bord de chars bruyants
fantasmer les hommes qu'ils imaginent
un monde du vin où tout est possible
puis ils inventent des miracles, le paradis
et l'enfer
résurrection réincarnation e
même la vie éternelle mais des dieux
haut de la bible elium elium pas
est d'accord avec ces ruminations
les humains et lyon déclarent que les dieux meurent
comme les hommes et les animaux et que
tous les êtres vivants disparaîtront dans
rien parce qu'il n'y a rien avant
chaque vie n'est rien après
la bible est un ensemble de textes écrits
par les Juifs après leur exil a
Babylone dans ce carrefour des cultures
Juifs rencontrent des disciples de
Zoroastre reste tellement convaincu par la
leur notion du dieu unique qu'ils décident
fonder une religion juive
monothéiste
[Musique]
les juifs ont déjà un dieu les élohim
clé et faites-lui confiance
dans le passé, les biens avaient conduit par
monter dans la terre promise et non
il va maintenant les abandonner en exil
Babylonien en effet
juste le temps d'une génération et le
Les Juifs retournent en Judée qu'ils construisent
le temple de jérusalem et l'institut
leur religion monothéiste les Juifs
ils savent que les élohim sont des dieux
des centaines mais proclamer yahve comme dieu
seul créateur du ciel et de la terre e
de l'homme
[Musique]
forment donc la bible hébraïque
en modifiant leurs textes anciens qui
adapter la version monothéiste
leur dieu biblique a créé Adam en commençant
d'une poignée d'argile
cependant la création d'eva est beaucoup plus
dieu travailleur doit anesthésier adam et
flèches de cellules souches e
suturer la coupe pour obtenir eva
[Musique]
tandis que le dieu unique fait son
apparition en palestine en grèce
en ces jours les dieux sont reniés et les
Les érudits grecs expliquent le corps
l'intellect et la mort d'une manière
rationnel
en même temps au népal budan dément
les dieux percevant l'homme comme un
esprit éternel qui vit différentes étapes
dont l'un est la condition humaine dans
Chine Laos et prêche la confiance en
la nature et dans le tao l'équilibre parfait
qui soutient l'univers
[Musique]
les liens qui s'entremêlent entre les
traditions du monde
il y a beaucoup d'axa chinois
correspondent aux satyres de la mythologie
les ensembles de corps européens vont aux indiens
correspondent aux anges et aux saints
buda est représenté comme un dieu grec et
jésus est encore un autre dieu qui devient homme
[Musique]
parce que trois mille ans avant Jésus-Christ
beaucoup de oui ont de nouveau incarné le dieu
l'indien zeus krishna est né d'un
vierge pour transfert de vin
échappe au massacre des innocents
bien prêcher
meurt, ressuscite et s'achève à Naples
[Musique]
en Grèce
Dieu Dionysos visite le royaume de la mort
transforme l'eau en vin
aussi meurt et ressuscite l'egypte est le
son dieu qui devient homme et fils d'horus
de la vierge isis la déesse égyptienne de la
lune enveloppée dans un manteau bleu
constellé d'étoiles ou russe est né le 25
Décembre dans une grotte sa naissance est
annoncé par une étoile et l'événement est
attendu par trois rois horus reçoit de l'or
l'encens et la myrrhe et baptisé à l'âge de
30 ans depuis anoop le baptiseur qui
sera décapité et suivi de 12
disciples luttent pendant 40 jours dans
désert contre dresser les méchants
[Musique]
délibérer les sermons et il meurt
puis ressuscité après trois jours ressuscite
aussi Lazare et marcher sur l'eau
[Musique]
représenté par une croix formée par le
Triade divine égyptienne Horus excité
comme le messie le fils oint du chemin
[Musique]
autour de l'année clé zéro est encore
alle lo im du peuple juif mais avec
l'occupation romaine de la Palestine
peur d'être chassé de vraies mains et sont
protégé par des élohim plus puissants que lui
alors j'en ai arrangé un
Rébellion juive contre les ordres romains
à son archange gabriel pour greffer
l'adn elohim sur certaines femmes juives
afin que ceux-ci enfantent des dieux
hommes supérieurs gabriella veut dire
porteur et ordres d'un élohim
dans l'Ancien Testament les biens qu'il possédait
une gabriella et quelques femmes ont déjà été envoyées
Juifs et ceux-ci avaient donné naissance à des dieux
des jumeaux comme des naissances multiples de
la fécondation in vitro
[Musique]
maintenant il avait une brienne ordinaire de
intervenir sur la cousine de la vierge
maria elisabetta générant john
baptiste et sur la même marie qui donne
à la lumière deux jumeaux
Joshua et Thomas Mary restent
symboliquement vierge parce qu'elle n'est pas
fécondé par un homme le temps de
une génération passe la rébellion
La juive est prête Jean le Baptiste s'enrôle
les subversifs juifs qu'ils ont déjà tués
des Romains se joignant à eux avec le serment de
baptême joshua juste là à
combattre les troupes romaines
et son ami peter s'occupe de
Le financement Giusuè est aussi appelé
barabbas qui veut dire fils de dieu
les rebelles savent qu'un envoyé de Dieu
clé quand Jean le Baptiste vient
Jésus décapité et Barabbas prend le
commandement de la rébellion et rassemble les
fou de trouver de nouveaux adhérents
[Musique]
mais le comportement de peter me dérange
niveaux
Peter tue un couple qui ne
avaient payé tous leurs avoirs
et cela effraie et se rebelle surtout
Judas qui avertit les Romains un régiment
les auxiliaires syriens à la solde de Rome
500 soldats entièrement armés partent
puis il va arrêter le dangereux chef
jésus rebelle et barabbas son jumeau
Thomas lui ressemble tellement qu'il conduit
Dois embrasser Jésus est pour que je
les soldats ne se trompent pas le préfet
Romain de Judée Ponce Pilate condamne
jésus et barabbas la crucifixion comme
insurgés mais les rebelles attendent le
les soldats partent et soudoient les gardiens
soustraire Josué encore vivant de
croix cache-le dans une tombe privée
et la nuit ils l'emmènent en lieu sûr
[Musique]
la répression romaine devient alors
sanglant
Jérusalem est sur le point d'être
détruit et les rebelles se donnent à
fuite
[Musique]
quelques livres très anciens qui se sont échappés
incendie des gardes rouges de mao tse
tung attestent que jésus et barabbas font
il se réfugie au Tibet et y reste un
dix ans son jumeau Thomas
connu pour la récitation du doigt dans le
la peste s'enfuit vers l'inde et sa tombe
existe encore
les Portugais ont débarqué dans le sud de l'Inde
16e siècle
ils témoignent
face à l'échec de son
rebellion ni lui ni la clé ne disparaissent
abandonnant la classe à son sort
Prêtre juif qui a peur d'être
dissous les Juifs vrais mains
ils conçoivent alors une nouvelle religion
plus approprié au public gréco-romain
et confie la réalisation à un
Érudit juif romain le notable Paul
du tarse
mais paul aussi appelé le castrat ou
le sole est un visionnaire comme dieu de
cette nouvelle religion
Paul choisit le juif jésus et barabbas
condamné 50 ans plus tôt par Ponce
Pilate
mais les romains ne sont pas un rebelle
ils n'accepteront jamais comme un dieu alors
paolo a une idée géniale il en invente deux
caractères distincts Josué et Barabbas
barabbas et rebelle libérés de pilate e
Josué et le nouveau dieu martyr qui est
sacrifier pour sauver l'humanité paolo fa
l'utilisation de la tradition orientale pour
fortifier la religion qui lui a été confiée
mais quand les Juifs comprendront ce qu'il veut
faire de l'homme jésus est un nouveau dieu
accuser de blasphème et vouloir
Peter veut même l'emprisonner
tue le mais paolo s'échappe par la mer oui
se réfugier en Grèce et poursuivre la
sa propre idée change d'abord le nom
Jésus est en Jésus l'associant au dieu
Zeus grec
alors toujours confiant dans l'efficacité
de traditions orientales le complète
en jésus christ pour l'associer au dieu
indien descendu hus krishna
[Musique]
enfin, s'inspirant de la triade divine
Paul rassemble la vie de Krishna
d'horus de dionysos composant la vie
de Jésus-Christ comme décrit dans
évangiles
[Musique]
rien à voir avec jésus et barabbas
qu'il a vraiment existé
[Musique]
paolo n'arrête pas de falsifier
bible hébraïque pour annoncer
l'avènement du Christ invente l'éternité
un concept qui n'existe pas chez les juifs
invente l'envoi de jésus sur terre
son sacrifice afin d'expier pour moi
péchés du monde et sa résurrection
croyant enfin que c'était le sien
castration pour l'approcher au revoir paul
empêche ses partisans d'accomplir
actes sexuels se différenciant ainsi des
religieux des autres coups qui
ils ont tous des femmes et des filles nonobstant
ce paul fait du bon travail
parce que sa combinaison des plus
touches de traditions efficaces et orientales
une infinité de coeurs
sa version donne lieu à la
La religion chrétienne et sa foi
croyants est si fort que les polythéistes
Romains après avoir persécuté
Les chrétiens accueillent le christianisme e
ils se font même baptiser
cependant vers l'an 300 a
le débat divise les savants eusebius le
Évêque chrétien de Césarée en Judée
crois que Dieu a inspiré la bible mais
le philosophe grec porphyre n'est pas
d'accord
porphyre soutient que la bible est une
copie falsifiée du manuscrit de
jerome ball le successeur de moïse en
cette écriture ancienne n'est pas là
ni elle ni l'éternité
mais seulement des événements qui
ils concernent la relation entre certains
extraterrestres du ciel ed
certains dirigeants du peuple juif
[Musique]
les anciens textes chinois et indiens
d'amérique centrale
citer le même type de relation
mais la pensée conventionnelle considère
ces écrits comme des fantasmes
[Musique]
aujourd'hui, cependant, avec l'éducation publique
accessibilité aux bibliothèques
nouvelles traductions génie génétique i
ordinateur internet et surtout avec le
la rationalité moderne que nous pouvons discerner
l'authentique du faux
tout au long de cette histoire
[Musique]
nous découvrirons alors que les textes actuels
sacrés sont des copies contrefaites de
écrits anciens sur Marie que chacun
religion adaptée à vos besoins
[Musique]
l'aboutissement est que ces remaniements
ils prennent des extraterrestres guerriers
comme de vrais dieux spirituels
même les soutenir dans l'adoration
dans les études comparatives du Vatican sur
textes anciens
la dernière traduction de la bible faire
abdiquer un père en forçant le sien
successeur le pape françois à affirmer
qu'il ne faut pas prendre le
la résurrection de jésus comme événement
historique
mais comme un acte de foi
[Musique]
le clergé catholique a alors défendu ai
ses privilèges millénaires accusant papa
François d'hérésie pour le sien
déclarations contraires à la vérité
scientifiques divins mais modernes
ils comprennent ce que sont leurs anciens
prédécesseurs ne pouvaient même pas
imaginez comment les navettes spatiales et les
manipulation génétique
aujourd'hui ces notions sont
deviennent beaucoup plus claires à la lumière de
ces faits un esprit rationnel
pourrait en déduire que jusqu'à la preuve de la
contraire
le monde spirituel des religions ne
ce n'est qu'une blague et cette histoire
des extraterrestres devenus dieux
dans la mémoire des hommes c'est le seul qui
propose une justification pour
énigmes de la protohistoire et peut-être
même aux origines de l'homme
enfin, à la fois comme c'est cette épopée et là
retient son souffle de temps en temps
suspendu et notre passé lointain un
passé plein de surprises
dont les changements sont toujours
passionnant comme les rebondissements de
théâtre
[Applaudissements]